[Music]
i want jamison williams but i also think
we need defense we're looking for our
boy
jameson williams
for jordan davis oh line is always
appreciated i just hope now he doesn't
get gq tonight and pick it up
i'm going to jordan davis i want to be
lyman
davis but i want williams howie roseman
i want to offer you my first born son if
you make the right pick for once don't
overthink it you know what i mean like
there's a lot of talent in this job i
see it i played college ball at the
highest level like we needed a
linebacker yeah
we need a lunch we need a lot of things
just chase the point
god bless your souls merry christmas i
want to throw up i'm not feeling good i
wanted stingley i wanted gartner i
wanted timido they're all gone i was
expecting a trade-up and it's all going
down the drainage
he's 360 pounds
we need
it all starts up front it starts in the
trenches so we already got a solid
d-line
jordan davis is going to make five plays
a game if that he's going to gain weight
he's going to do nothing
why not hamilton
how many defensive tackles are we gonna
take
give me an edge rusher maybe but why not
hamilton
oh my gosh
do you guys like asmr i'm the happiest
eagles fan alive
how do we know what time it is it's her
season it's it's devonte smith season
it's aj brown season it's jordan davis
season it's philly season we're getting
better our whole way we're winning a
chip that's all i got to say baby
[Music]